we're joined now by dr anthony fauci
he's president biden's chief medical
advisor and the country's top expert
on infectious diseases dr fauci good
morning uh we
heard we heard what the president said
there everybody eligible by
the middle of the month but supply is
still in
uh is still short of demand a lot of
people having trouble making
appointments
why is that well you know it's getting
better and better by the day i mean if
you just look around the country we're
seeing that there was
a gap between supply and demand and
literally every day that goes by
if that gap is closing and that's the
reason why the president was able to
make that statement
pushing up the date when people would be
essentially
everyone would be eligible to receive
the vaccine so although there were some
issues regarding early on
that the demand clearly outstripped the
supply
that's closing down that gap is closing
and that's really good news
you know we're now going between three
and four million
doses per day uh and every day that goes
by
it gets us further and further towards
that goal
of being able to get ahead of any
possible surge
so all that you've just said right now
is actually all good news
what do you how do you feel about the
progress we're making towards herd
immunity we had
we had a report earlier in this
broadcast about half of republican men
say they don't want to take the vaccine
are you concerned about the resistance
of course i am i mean that's something
that we really need to do
we have we have already three
emergency use authorization approved
vaccines that are highly
efficacious in the clinical trials and
when you look in the real world
results following the eua the results
are even
better so we're really very fortunate
that we have
these vaccines the more people we get
vaccinated the greater protection we
have not only for the individual
but for society in general and that's
the reason why
we're putting such a big push in trying
to get people to be convinced to get
vaccinated you know we have this
uh kovit 19 community corps
which is getting trusted messengers be
they clergy
sports figures uh athletic figures
people that the community trust and look
up to
we're getting information to them to be
able to better articulate the need and
the importance
to get vaccinated so we're paying a lot
of attention and trying to win over
those people
who for a variety of reasons are
hesitant to get vaccinated we've got to
do that
dr voucher i'm so worried i remember you
saying listen america hold on
you know it's like spiking the ball on
the five-yard line we can see the finish
line but we're not at the finish line
yet
so i've really taken that to heart but
this is the thing the covet cases are
going up
also the states are reopening that texas
game the other day people sitting
shoulder to shoulder some with mass some
without mass
do you think it's okay for us to now go
to places because
i look at this i see super spreader is
it okay for us to go to events
wearing a mask well you know it depends
on the level of virus in the community
gail that's the important point and
that's the thing that i
and several of my colleagues in the
public health arena the director of the
cdc and others are saying
every day that goes by we get closer and
closer to where we want to be
and we don't want people now all of a
sudden to declare victory prematurely
and then feed into what is a potential
surge what we are seeing if you look at
the numbers every day
we had that peak we came down we
plateaued and we got stuck
there now we're starting to inch up and
several states
have increases in cases as opposed to a
leveling off and decreasing
we've got to hang in there and not
completely pull back
on several of the mitigation methods of
public health
because if we do that we're tempting
another surge
and as i mentioned you balance that
against the vaccine because every day we
hang on
and don't allow a surge to occur is an
advantage to us
because every day we get three to four
million more people vaccinated
that is critical if we do that for a new
another few weeks to a month or more
we're going to be ahead of the game and
that surge won't occur yeah
it's just it's common sense yeah but dr
fauci
there will come a point where we have
vaccines available but there's a
hardened population that doesn't want
them
in terms of getting the vaccine to those
people or getting those people to take
it
many businesses are debating right now
whether to make a vaccine a requirement
of people coming into the office or
doing business with that business if
it's an event from a public health
perspective because there's a legal
conversation that's separate from a
public health perspective
do you support that kind of policy you
know
um i i don't think i could come out and
officially say i support it because
that's gonna
be taken i think out of context in some
cases
i can tell you one thing that they're
almost certainly going to be
what you just predicted namely that
there are going to be organizations they
could be universities they could be
commercial organizations which are going
to do just what you indicated
they're going to say we're not going to
have you come in unless you get
vaccinated you're not going to see that
from a federal government mandate but i
mean i would be very surprised if we did
not see that
at the local level well from a public
health perspective do you think it would
help
at the local level you know what i would
say that from a public health
standpoint the more people we would get
vaccinated
yes it would help the better off we
would be
all right dr anthony fauci thank you
very much good to be with you thank you
for having me